shawn mendes is proving that you can
really be friends with your ex and still
have love for them uh yeah so last
friday sean released a new track called
when you're gone which seemingly dives
into his breakup with camila cabello
according to sean he wrote the new song
about a month after his split with
camila and while joining on air with
ryan seacrest yesterday sean reveals how
writing the song helped with his healing
process
i'm really glad to be able to just be
real and be be authentic with my music
because it's cathartic for me too to be
able to write about these things and
then it's amazing because i get to hear
how people are possibly going through
the same thing so
and although sean and camilla broke up
last november after two years of dating
the singer says there's no hard feelings
but in a lot of ways i think like a
breakup can be a blessing too because it
can really kind of show you that you are
which is necessary you know so
yeah when you guys have stayed friendly
friendly i mean
i've loved camilla first for so many
years and and that that's never going to
change so
yeah it will
wow listen it will no we will they're
young you can't say i love her and
that'll never change it'll change and
that's fine but i uh i it's interesting
when you sort of see these because we've
we're in a generation of younger stars
right now where where the breakups and
the songs can come so fast after a
breakup and they were simultaneously
sort of releasing tracks um about each
other like it was almost like chris
jenner played the whole thing right like
it almost seemed like it was a it was a
branding rollout of sorts um but but i
like both of their i like both of their
new songs i like shawn's new song and um
and it looks like he was heartbroken and
is sort of on his way back to healing i
guess you know what i love the fact that
they have music to as their outlet
they're able to communicate that that
way but once you put in your music
you're going to be questioned for every
lyric when you're doing interviews
people are going to say so what did you
mean by this what did you do that so i
don't know if it's a safe thing to do
but it looks like it's amicable and
they're they're friends and and you will
love her forever because it was his
first
really long strong relationship
not forever